a New York Times story may have
backfired in spectacular fashion with a
new report that may indicate that the
Obama administration did in fact spy in
the Trump campaign buried deep in
yesterday's piece on the origins of the
Russia probe more than 40 paragraphs
down is this revelation at least one
government informant met several times
with Carter page and George papadopolis
current and former officials said
president Trump reacted to the
revelation by tweeting that it could be
bigger than Watergate but was this
really a misstep by The Times or was it
done on purpose Roger stone stone
rejoins us for reaction to this major
development also Fox News contributor
and Federalist senior editor Molly
Hemingway and former whitewater
prosecutor Saul Weissenberg saw your
reaction to that little nugget that was
buried in the New York Times piece well
it's absolutely shocking and very
improper in my view that the FBI
apparently penetrated and had an
undercover person on the Trump campaign
and that they use the lesser standards
of a counterintelligence investigation
playing that for us for people who don't
understand to open counter-intel
investigation you don't need a criminal
predicate correct well you you don't
need a criminal predicate and it's one
thing to say they should have they could
have had enough evidence to open an
investigation of whether there is
Russian espionage but certainly they
weren't close to being anywhere near
able to say we have some evidence of
espionage by people in the Trump
campaign and they never could have
opened a criminal investigation based on
that and so instead they used the excuse
of counterintelligence it's it's very
it's a huge scandal it's and you're
absolutely right it was put in that
story because they knew it was going to
come out and they're trying to be able
to say that's old news and that's not
really a big deal Wow yeah I think it's
not that this might be happening that
the FBI was spying but what we have now
are multiple former FBI officials fully
saying that there was broad surveillance
on the Trump campaign that it wasn't
just Carter page but it was four
separate high-ranking individuals that
it was wiretap
there were national security letters and
at least one human intelligence source
about whom you know we don't know a lot
how many how many there were were they
sent in by the FBI were they walk-ins I
mean there's so much information to find
out but it's not a question of that this
might indicate that they're spying
they're saying they spied and they're
saying they did it in a pretty broad
fashion remember when Trump was
ridiculed by everyone when he said they
you know I was wiretap t he speaks in
short handed to Twitter I was wired to
apt or whatever that tweet what he meant
surveilled yeah hey Matt surreal he was
right he was absolutely right Judge
Andrew Napolitano right here on Fox was
the first one to call this look this has
to be seen in context not only did they
use a phony fabricated dossier as the
underlying legal rationale for the
spying on the Republican candidate for
president using the power and the
authority and the capability of the
state to spy on one of the two major
party candidates and abuse of power but
now they infiltrated the Trump campaign
with a FBI agent this makes Watergate
looked like small potatoes it looks like
this guy Stephan helper who teaches at
Cambridge he's American citizen he's
bushy neocon guy you know you know I'm
right I played poker with him he's an
excellent play apparently but he it
looks like they've been reported Daily
Caller others I know
de Genovese on this he might have been
someone who suggested was trying to
suggest a lot of things to the Trump
campaign and but he didn't work for the
Trump campaign but it was reported that
he approached many different Trump
campaign people to try to give them
information what do you make of that
song well you would you would call that
a potential entrapment an agent
provocateur in the campaign I hadn't
heard that yet but it wouldn't
necessarily surprise me but but the it's
shocking enough that based on the kind
of flimsy evidence that they had that
they would put somebody into the
campaign
the FISA is disturbing enough because we
know they didn't reveal something very
important very important to the FISA
Court but to have a plant in the
political campaign of your opponent
you do something like that you better
have dynamite and it looks like they
didn't have dynamite and you know it's
all part of a pattern the pattern of
Sally Yates investigating Mike Flynn for
the Logan Act it's all part of a very
distinguished out defending all this
yesterday there's an additional problem
with this which is Congress is currently
trying to find out information about
these types of things and the FBI is
telling them that they can't turn over
that information at the same time you're
seeing leaks with personally identifying
biographical and you know career
information about this source that was
used and there's at least one source
they're telling the New York Times
they're telling the Washington Post but
they won't turn over the information to
Congress which is actually because they
want to make themselves look as good as
possible before this IG thing comes out
and before other documents come out I
mean this narrative is being painted
buried burying the lede in the New York
Times and Roger Rudy just said Sean
Hannity show that they are discussing
with Muller now narrowing the scope of
the questions I don't like him going in
talking to Bob Muller at all because I
don't like the whole I think this whole
thing stinks to high heaven but it looks
like they've made progress on narrowing
the questions I made this point on M
fours the other day
there's no circumstance under which the
president should should go in for an
interview
it's a perjury trap and the idea that
that rod Rosenstein and Jeff Sessions
will not turn over to Congress a
co-equal branch of government
information regarding the surveillance
of the Trump campaign with the
illegitimate use of FISA warrants that
is an impeachable offense Obama had no
knowledge of this on the contrary what
did the president know and when did he
know it how does how does the President
of the United States not know that we
are doing a counter-intel investigation
on the opponent of the woman who would
succeed him
Peter Struck's text messages indicate
the president wanted to know everything
they've tried to explain that away I
always go back to Susan Rice's email to
herself on an Argand a president wanted
everything done by the book she said it
twice right after noon on January 20th I
that thing I get chills when I talk to
you I yeah exactly saw what about
narrowing the scope of those questions
is that is that giving you any sense of
comfort that they would go in there and
answer questions by Muller given
everything
we now know as I've said many times on
this show if if Donald Trump if he were
any white-collar client any regular
white-collar client famous or not famous
in this circumstance I would physically
prevent him from going in for that
questioning and on the point that Roger
raised about the information that the
DOJ doesn't want to give over there are
good reasons for not giving over sources
and methods the problem with the with
the DOJ particularly with the FBI is
they've been caught saying several times
we can't turn this over because it's
sensitive and when they back down and
they unredacted it's just embarrassing
they they have a credibility problem
malee Papadopoulos they kept saying
Papadopoulos was this big impetus for
the investigation the more we learn
about that I mean I'm sorry but he just
seems like a goofball I mean I don't
know him but he's like Carter page I
mean Papen appleís this is like the
ridiculous I mean just look at these
foods they're not exactly you know
characters you'd imagine like compiling
information and try to get with the
Russians but nevertheless we keep
learning more about who was approaching
him at the time right we the more we
learn you know at first we were told
there were all these questions about
Russian interference and involvement
with the Trump campaign the more we
learn about what led them to think that
it boggles the mind that professionals
would actually have started much of any
investigation at all over over these
very piddling things and yet they did
and yet they did and they're now
admitting they were spying on you know
at least four Trump campaign officials
and that they were using the entire
powers of the intelligence apparatus to
do this regardless of what you think
about Donald Trump this is such a
horrible precedent to be spying on
political opponents and to be doing it
with and to be avoiding accountability
it's not a new right the New York Times
reported on January 20th of 2017 that
there was a FISA warrant on may I've
talked to those reporters they will not
retract their story
I've asked through a FOIA request for
information it's been denied we're going
to move to it that's right I'm sorry I'm
not saying this as a Republican or
conservative I find it frightening that
the power of the federal government
could be used in this manner and the in
the middle of a political season
with spurious or scant evidence we're
out of time guys I wish we could hold
you guys for the our fantastic panel